we are on problem number 12 problem 12
what is the gray okay what is the
greatest of five consecutive integers if
the sum of these integers is 185 so what
is the greatest so let's assume X is the
greatest and their consecutive integers
so what's the second to gratis well that
would be X minus 1 the third the
greatest would be X minus 2 X minus 3
and X minus 4 right these are five
consecutive integers where x is the
largest right right if this you know if
X was 150 x minus 4 would be you know
these numbers would be 150 149 148 147
146 like that right so these are
consecutive integers X is the largest
and they're telling us that the sum the
sum is 185 so the sum is equal to 185 so
what is this some how do we sum these up
so we have 5 x's right so we get 5x and
then what's minus 1 minus 2 minus 3
minus 4 1 plus two is three 3 plus 3 is
this where I always mess up 3 plus 3 is
6 6 plus 4 is 10 right so you get 5x
minus 10 is equal to 185 add 10 to both
sides 5x is equal to 195 and you could
eyeball this you could say well how many
times does 5 go into you can say how
many times does 5 go into to 200 and
it's going to be one less than that
right five goes into 200 well it goes
into it 40 times so it'll be 39 or you
could divide 39 if you don't if you
didn't want to do it that way you could
say five goes into 195 33 times 5 is 15
4539 so that's our answer X is 39 it's
the largest of the consecutive number so
those numbers are 39 38 37 36 35 those
are five consecutive numbers next
problem problem there teen
a salesman's monthly gross pay consists
of twelve hundred dollars twelve hundred
dollars plus twenty percent of the
dollar amount of a sales so plus twenty
percent of the sales st i'll say for
sales if his gross pay for one month was
twenty five hundred dollars so in this
month his gross pay was twenty five
hundred dollars what was the dollar
amount of his sales for that month well
when i read it i essentially set up this
equation right his compositions twelve
hundred plus twenty percent of the sales
and we know that that equals twenty five
hundred in this month so let's subtract
1,200 from both sides so you get point 2
s is equal to what's this 1300 right and
so s is equal to 1300 / point2 and the
way i like to think about this point to
instead of having to do this decimal
which you could do is we i could have
rewritten this twenty percent is the
same thing as 1 5th right so it's also
one-fifth s is equal to 1300 and now
this is easy multiply both sides by 5
you get s is equal to 13 hundred times 5
which equals 1 13 times five is 65 and
add the two zeros so s is equal to 6,500
dollars that's the monthly sales that
month as a little redundant with the
word monthly just now next problem
problem 14 okay so they've drawn a
circle and then let's see they've told
us that they've told us that this is
that this is let's see they tell us that
this is 40 degrees tell us that this is
40 degrees but they want to know oh
let's see Naomi make silver jewelry for
one style of hearing she cuts wedges
from a silver disk which i guess is
depicted here as shown in the figure
above each wedge makes a 40 degree angle
at the center of the disk if the weight
of each uncut disc is a uniformly
distributed 2.5 grams 2.5 grams that's
how much this whole silver disk I should
have done it in gray instead of magenta
because it's silver but anyway it's 2.5
grams how many grams does each wedge way
so we essentially just have to figure
out what fraction of the entire circle
is each wedge well it's each wedge is 40
degrees of a pot well how many degrees
are in the entire circle hopefully the
second nature to you by now but there's
360 degrees in the entire circle right
so the wedge is what fraction of the
entire circle well it's each wedge is 40
over 360 360 s 40 over 360 of the entire
circle and that's what that's equal 19
divided on the bottom by 40 right 4 goes
into 36 right nine times so each wedge
is one ninth of the entire circle I just
did that based on the fact that it's 40
degrees forty degrees over 360 degrees
so if each wedge is one ninth of the
entire silver piece and the silver piece
weighs 2.5 grams then each wedge will
weigh so a wedge will weigh 19 times two
point two point five grams alright and
and if we want to write 2.5 as a as a as
a fraction how do we do that that might
be convenient right now I'll tell you
that's the same thing now you can
multiply it out and that's all fine but
you could also recognize that 2.5 can
also be written as 9 over 4 I don't know
it can't
2.5 can be written as 5 over 4 no as I'm
pathetic 2.5 can be written as 10 / 4
right because 4 goes into 10 2 times
then why am I even writing 10 / 4 see my
brain is malfunctioning 2.5 can be
written as 5 over 2 which is 10 / 4 but
I I was somehow thinking in number 9 and
I'm not going to make excuses for my my
deficits anyway so what's 19 stime 5
halves it's five 18th so each wedge is
going to wait 5 18th of a gram the other
option is you could have divided 2.5 x 9
and you would have gotten another answer
with decimals either one would have
worked because these are free answer
questions next problem can you actually
use a calculator on the s80 these days
if you can and that would have been an
option as well problem 15 if x squared
minus y squared is equal to 10 and X
plus y is equal to 5 what is X minus y
before I even read the rest of the
question when I saw this it should be
like your knee-jerk reaction you take
the X 80 when you see x squared minus y
squared equals 10 you say well that's
the same thing as X plus y times X minus
y is equal to 10 you just factored this
difference of squares immediately you
almost can do that before you read the
rest of the question and they tell us
what's X plus y X plus y is 5 so 5 times
X minus y is equal to 10 divide both
sides by 5 you get X minus y is equal to
2 that's it next problem so they give
they dress let me
colors so they draw us a rectangle and
then within that rectangle there is
another rectangle or it looks like this
another square really and what I've
drawn doesn't look that much like a
square but it's close enough I think you
get the idea and this is obviously a
right angle right angle right angle
right angle they tell us the dis
distance is too this distance is three
in the figure above what is the area of
the shaded square so this is a bit of a
trick and actually let me do it in the
next video so i can kind of a delve
deeper into the trick i'll see you in
the next video